هل تستطيع امريكا تعويض نقص الصواريخ في
مخزونها بسبب ما تم ارساله لكياف حتى الان
الاجابه نعم لكن المده المتوقعه لذلك هي
اكثر من عقد في الاشهر العشره الاولى من
الحرب في اوكرانيا وافقت واشنطن على ثلاثه
وثلاثين مليار دولار من المساعدات
العسكريه لكياف الدعم شمله كميات او شمل
كميات ضخمه من صواريخ سنجر ما سبب نقصا في
المخزون الامريكي يتطلب تعويضه 13 عاما
بمستويات الانتاج العاليه الحاليه ايضا
ستحتاج المصانع الامريكيه لخمس سنوات
لسد النقص الذي سببه ارسال هذه الصواريخ
الى اوكرانيا
الرئيسيه لما يحدث هو ان كياف تستهلك
ذخائر اكثر من ما تنتجه الولايات المتحده
اذا قربنا الصوره اكثر تنتج الولايات
المتحده قذائف عيار 155 ملم اي بمعدل اربع
عشره الف طلقه شهريا رقم ربما يبدو كبيرا
كانتاج شهري لكن خلال المعارك استهلكت
القوات الاوكرانيه انتاج شهر كامل في
يومين فقط الاضطراب في المخزون الامريكي
دفع واشنطن للتفكير بحلول من بينها
الاستعانه بالمخازن الامريكيه في دول اخرى
وتكثيف الانتاج بشكل عام لا تشهد الولايات
المتحده نقصا حادا في مخزون اسلحتها وكحل
الازمه اقترح البيت الابيض هذا الشهر
زياده بنسبه 51% في ميزانيه شراء الصواريخ
والذخائر مقارنه بالعام الماضي لتصل الى
30 مليارا و600 مليون دولار